salut à tous ce christophe pour la
chronique politique depuis la mort de
georges floyd fin mai aux états unis
des manifestations anti raciste et
contre les violences policières ont lieu
un peu partout dans le monde dont la
déclinaison française se fait autour du
cade adama traoré lors d'une de ces
manifestations un gendarme noir a été
traité de vendu par les manifestants
d'autres membres des forces de l'ordre
issus de l'immigration ont droit à tous
les épithètes vendu traître bundy c'est
à dire noir dehors mais blanc à
l'intérieur arabes de service voire
[ __ ] de maison
c'est au point d'ailleurs que certains
policiers noirs et maghrébins ont
récemment publié une tribune pour se
défendre de ces insultes aujourd'hui
pour comprendre la charge symbolique de
ces insultes je vous propose de nous
intéresser à l'une d'entre elles en
particulier la plus choquante pour nos
oreilles françaises peu habitués aux
termes raciaux [ __ ] de maison
alors d'où vient cette expression elle a
été inventée en 1963 par malcom x
à l'occasion d'un discours dans ce
discours malcom x distinguer deux types
de mentalité d'afro-américains les
[ __ ] de maisons et les [ __ ]
deschamps il faisait référence à la
période de l'esclavagé et pour lui il y
avait deux sortes d'esclaves ceux qui
vivaient auprès des maîtres les
serviteurs de maison malcom x considéré
que ces esclaves là et est servile et
heureux de leur condition qu'il
s'identifiait à leurs maîtres et était
quelque part plus royaliste que le roi
qu'ils aimaient leurs chaînes et
mépriser les autres esclaves employés
aux travaux de force
c'est un peu le syndrome de l'oncle tom
les esclaves employés dans les champs à
eux toujours selon malcom x aurait eu
une tout autre mentalité
il aurait détesté leurs maîtres et
n'aurait souhaitait qu'une chose leur
mort a eu contrairement aux domestiques
aurez compris la nature de l' esclavage
et y aura résisté au moins mentalement
malcom x voyait au sein de la communauté
afro-américaine de son époque le même
genre d'attitude que sous l' esclavage
le terme [ __ ] de maison lui servait à
fustiger les noirs qu'il jugeait trop
timorés dans la lutte pour les droits
civiques en particulier martin luther
king pour lui les noirs de les faire
sans les blancs pour obtenir des droits
surtout il faut bien comprendre le
contexte de l'époque
en 1963 quand il prononce cette
expression malcom x est encore membre de
la neige
office l'âme une secte professant un
islam racialiste et se revendiquant du
nationalisme noir un nationalisme qui
prône le séparatisme ethnique aux usa
pour la nation of islam les blancs et
les juifs sont des races démoniaque
contrairement à lara cellule la race
noire marcher main dans la main avec les
blancs c'est donc s'acoquiner avec le
mal avec le mal avec un m majuscule
alors bien sûr cette division entre
esclaves est artificielle c'est une
caricature a posteriori qui a un but
avant tout politique divisée une
communauté entre les bons et les mauvais
en faisant appel à des stéréotypes
historique dégradants ou glorieux selon
le camp choisi
il s'agit de vie lire l'adversaire à
l'aide de supposées précédent historique
marqué du sceau de l'infamie dans
l'esprit collectif cette méthode
correspond à peu près à ce qu'on a chez
nous avec l'éternel argument historique
sur la seconde guerre mondiale selon
chacun d'entre nous ceux qui auraient
été des collabos à l'époque sont
étonnamment toujours ce que l'on déteste
dans le champ politique actuelle ces
insultes vendu traître bounty arabes de
service --dont [ __ ] de maison n'est que
la plus explicite d'entre toutes
10 tout en fin de compte la même chose
tu appartiens à ta race avant
d'appartenir au corps civique français
tués noirs ou maghrébins avant d'être
citoyen voilà la pensée des antiracistes
de 2020 personnellement tout cela me
rappelle une interview qui avait donné
il ya une dizaine d'années un néonazi du
cru un groupuscule d'ultra droite il
avait dit texto que le seul uniforme qui
comptait dans la vie c'était la couleur
de peau
les antiracistes de 2020 ont réussi à
converger intellectuellement avec un néo
nazis des années 2010 bref toujours est
il que si cette courte vidéo réalisé un
petit peu à l'arraché vous a intéressé
et bien n'hésitez pas à la partager et à
vous abonner et sur ce il ne me reste
plus qu'à vous dire à la prochaine